je sais pas à quel point tu as de la
place ou pas pour ta came
c'était face à un mur parce quand tu
tournes c'est compliqué mais en gros
avec la focale ce qui se passe est que
plus tu as de zoomer et loin plus j'ai
compris alors on va tourner comme ça
bonjour à tous les ars avec c'est le
sujet de cette vidéo alors déjà je vous
déteste pas vous les insectes tout
d'abord d'où ça vient cette idée de
vidéos bah ça bien qu'il ya quelques
jours j'ai très mal dans pourquoi parce
que madame moustiques elle a décidé
qu'elle allait chasser et elle m'a
chassé fort elle matraquer toute la nuit
ce bruit fait partie du top 3 des
pierres week-end humain peut entendre
après à celui là et enfin celui là bref
les insectes c'est un truc avec lequel
je suis très peu familier même les
insectes cool moi même pas genre un
papillon ça me fait un peu bad et je
trouve ça beau et tout c'est cool mais
c'est aussi j'ai un peu peur j'ai trouvé
une vidéo qui illustre parfaitement ce
que je veux vous dire c'est un truc qui
concerne les abeilles les abeilles c'est
l'un des insectes les plus utiles de
tous les insectes ne serait ce que pour
la pollinisation et en plus une abeille
quand elle te pique elmer contrairement
à une guêpe qui peut te piquer à
l'infini et tout [ __ ] ta mère une
abeille si elle fait le choix de se
battre et de te piquer elle y laisse sa
vie qu'elle être vaillant quelle
bravoure donc généralement à moins
qu'elles se sentent fortement danger ou
qu'elles sentent le groupe en danger ou
sa reine elle va pas de piquer la veille
et même en sachant ça je me chie dessus
une vidéo pour illustrer parfaitement ce
dont je vous parle c'est celle ci c'est
très simple c'est un mec il ya une
abeille qui est tombé dans sa piscine et
il met sa main pour l'aider à grimper et
elles ne piquent pas du tout et il la
dépose sur une petite plante le temps
qu'elle sèche et qu'elles puissent voler
de nouveau et continuer son dur labeur
qu'est la pollinisation je suis pas
capable de faire ça pas du tout en fait
je crois que j'ai jamais été piqué par
une abeille ou une guêpe du coup je sais
pas ce que ça fait quand tu te fais
piquer et du coup j'ai dix fois plus
peur que quelqu'un qui s'est déjà fait
piquer et qui sait ce que ça fait
aujourd'hui du coup c'est une vidéo un
peu comme celle qu'on a fait sur la
terrasse aux phobies et sur les
araignées on va en apprendre un peu plus
sur les insectes on va aussi de
découvrir des insectes vraiment badens
pour le coup comme ça on va relativiser
vis-à-vis des abeilles et d'autres trucs
et on va être peut-être plus avenant
pour ok c'est parti un nid de guêpes
formé autour d'un masque plus que ce
[Musique]
mais là on dirai clairement cardiaque
est mort et que ces restes à comment
j'aimerais pas découvrir les gammes chez
moi déjà cette texture là elle est
diabolique je suis désolé cette texture
de nids de guêpes frelons et où elle est
regardée une ruche d'abeilles c'est beau
amener des trolls ont tout est dit déjà
tu sais quel insecte est cool est bon
pour la planète
et quel insecte est juste là pour
décimer les autres c'est terrible d'être
connus et reconnus non mes mecs un
phasme les gars qui dansent ou pas le
fasse mais c'est le frérot c'est la
famille le fasse il a tout compris et la
masterisé le camouflage du bateau n'est
bon j'avoue je dis que c'est marrant
sympa et tout mais pareil je le
prendrais pas dans mes moins clairement
lui peut-être lui beaucoup moins
beaucoup moins
messieurs dames je vous ai parlé des
game je vous ai dit que c'étaient des
êtres diabolique regard des
confirmations total maintenant il s'agit
d'une gamme qui s'est fait couper la
tête probablement dans un combat contre
d'autres guerres contre les fraudes
n'importe quel étudiant il perd sa tête
ses tubes se finit pas elle est là elle
cherche sa tête tranquillement non mais
c'est incroyable puis elle s'envole avec
il s'envole
direction l'hôpital après s'il ya des
animaux qui arrivent à vivre genre
quelques secondes une minute sans leur
tête donc la guerre fait peut-être
partie ce qui la rend encore plus
dangereux qu'est ce que c'est que ça
quoi
ok apparemment c'est pour se défendre il
fait ça là des rois que j'ai vu ça c'est
quand j'ai claqué des boutons devant le
miroir quand j'étais ado tout y'a rien
de plus
franchement c'est horrible le principe
juste de voler le sens d'un autre animal
ok pour survivre c'est dingue
ah ouais ah ouais [ __ ] je pensais pas
autant mais si vous tombez sur ça dans
la vie brûler le tout sans hésiter nerfs
6 2 au 20 avril chez nous il nous mange
quoi c'est un petit couteau le truc et
de découpe délicatement pour laisser
place à la pompe
ça me gratte jugeait sa gratte à des
endroits là ça y est c'est sympa ces
images ils ont dit un mec bon gros
audiard moustiques qui va te graille
toute la journée mais pour la science
c'est fou ça m'a dégoûté
j'accepterai encore moins de me faire
piquer par des moustiques mois dans le
piège mortel des fours millions alors je
sais que c'est maxence qui est passionné
des fourmis et c'est vraiment incroyable
il ya une hiérarchie elles ont des rôles
spécifiques enfin c'est vraiment très
bien organisé on dirige part d'humain
c'est drôle mais vraiment ils sont hyper
bien organisé c'est assez ouf
alors là on suit une bande de fourmi qui
est dans le désert et jean ya des cônes
dans le sable en fait il ya un prédateur
qui se cache là dedans et qui essaient
de choper les fourmis qui tombe dans
l'école
ic insights beach je ne sais quoi qui se
cache dans le sable du coup
au super duo [ __ ] mais il leur smash
la gueule il est horrible cet insecte
elle va s'en sortir sans y arriver
oui
ouais aaa
le petit regret c'est qu'elle très chaud
cucquois un parasite prend le dessus sur
son hôte en contrôlant son corps quoi
êtes sûr mais nibali s'exposent les
images sont sublimes [ __ ] mais comment
ils ont exposé j'ai cru que ça touche à
ma portée je prends cet écran casse
on n'allait pas bien elle est pas bien
du tout four c'est ça ta g tonne de pâte
à crêpes whaou mais on est dans alien ça
fait une antenne et ça donne la 4g aux
champignons
au lycée bourse pause ouah ouah c'est
dingue
en fait je pense pas qu'ils avaient des
parasites qui tue est la cible est
ensuite poussé directement à partir du
cadavre
ça fout hausse acda alors ça au japon
ils ont un vrai fantasme sur ces
insectes là j'ai oublié le nom
malheureusement je sais même que dans
une enclave mais je crois c'est dans
naruto à chaque fois ils essaient d'en
attraper un essai super rare et c'est au
japon ils en vendent dans des petites
boîtes qu'ensuite tués dans des pogroms
chez toi et ça coûte genre 200 balles
quoi ces rares et ils ont un vrai qui
sur ces insectes la start up a fini iman
ste rose fighting sahara demeure the
round
ils sont marrant je trouve mais ils font
pas peur en fait ils sont assez drôle je
trouve de technique il switch nous
voyons le carreau un groupe rock you and
rising craven c'est vraiment le jeu du
pouce s'est inspiré de cette bête il va
tomber
[Musique]
queen latifah empire mais c'est un jeu
vidéo quoi cet arbre chaque étage est un
ennemi et doit tous les [ __ ] pour
attendre la femelle c'est incroyable
allez la latte respecte la prison
[Musique]
quoi mais c'est le pire lui mais c'est
le plus gros charolais et l'affrontent
d'état d'adversaire pour enfin accéder à
l'amour de sa vie et après l'avoir kane
il l'a fait tomber de l'arbre
directement on peut finir sur un petit
reddick du coup il a retiré 10 sur les
insectes cas c'est cool etc et bojan qui
va nous mettre bien tu vois je retire
tout ce que j'ai dit c'est vraiment un
crabe déguisées en papillons ça va pas
du tout à une mante religieuse noir
incroyable voire en fait c'est vraiment
des boxes cl font vraiment ce truc de
gauche droite comme ça c'est incroyable
soit la mante religieuse et relaxante à
la vue je trouve je ne la prend pas dans
ma main pour autant et voilà c'est cela
c'est cela qu'ils adorent au japon du
coup c'est pas du tout celui que j'ai
dit mais ça ressemble voyez c'est un peu
la même matière est tout sauf qu'ils ont
des alibis vol j'ai dit que la mère de
vote plus haut mais non c'est une mante
religieuse qui défend haut c'est la
chose la plus mignonne
j'aimerais qu'on se ressemble tous les
moustiques du mordant montre les yeux
s'il vous plaît bon façon c'est toujours
pareil genre j'ai très peur quand je me
suis pas renseigné dès que je suis en
train de manger qui a une guêpe ou une
abeille qui vient je suis pas bien du
tout mais en fait pour te faire pitié
gratos sans aucune raison faut vraiment
pas croire de chansons engagées
ambitions enfin bref c'était très
intéressant j'adore en ce moment
profitez de cette chaîne youtube pour
m'intéresser à des trucs où je prends
pas le temps de le faire habituellement
et le fait de le faire en vidéo fait que
déjà janvier faire puisque c'est une
vidéo et donc c'est un moment un peu
cool avec vous et en plus je vais le
faire sérieusement quoi l'âge et
continue de traîner sur sa ping sauvage
j'adore faire des vidéos comme ça on
découvre des trucs ensemble on apprend
des choses tout ça vraiment cool
on a un peu moins dans l'ignorance en
fait vis-à-vis de pas mal de sujets donc
merci avoir regardé je vous dis à
bientôt
portez vous bien haut
[Musique]